you have been under the deep
conviction that you are what you look
like with a head all right you got that
going but now pause and look for
yourself
and take seriously what you actually
experience
there isn't anything here except space
for the whole world
sam harris says that the implications of
the headless way provide insights into
the nature of the mind
which he considers to be among the most
important things that he's ever learned
why do you think that the realization of
not-self is so impactful
because it's true it's just the simple
truth
i mean i'm looking at you chris and i
know some people are just listening
but you can imagine but i see your face
i don't see mine
and i know from the outside we're face
to face
i understand that but my own direct
experience
is face to no face so i say i've got
your face instead of mine
i'm built open for you and that is
verifiable now i'm not going by
what someone has told me i'm actually
just looking
and enjoying having your face and you've
got mine you see so we call it trading
phases
so that is available it's verifiable
and it's loving actually because you're
seeing that you're built open to others
and welcoming the world in your
open space here and all the viewer or
listener has to do is
is look for for their own face
notice you can't see it you see a bit of
your nose coming out of nowhere and
there are sensations right but they
don't add up to
this uh to being inside a head
so i i hardly use the word non-dual i
i just um it that seems to sort of
because i like the jewel as well you see
it's important to remain aware of
yourself as separate
you see well we've got that we don't
really have to work on that
now now we uh return back to our own
point of view and see
you know are you looking out two eyes or
one opening you see
and there's one opening and you
you can't miss that i think you can't
actually see your head
and you can't do it wrong because you
can't sort of half see your headlessness
and you know so
uh and uh the headless way uh it really
started with douglas harding back in the
1940s and he was asking the question who
am i
and finally and he realized well there's
this model you were mentioning so
for those who can't see it's a model
with layers and
douglas designed this and it shows you
that
at a certain range you see this is your
center there no thing
emptiness no face and then at a certain
range
six feet you're a person but further
away you know
you're a city and then a planet
and a star in the galaxy or closer to
your cells you see
so this is this is verifiable if someone
looked at you and said you said what am
i
i say well from here you're chris but if
i went way up you'd be the planet earth
and if i came in close to you you'd be
cells now the question is
what is at the center of all these
layers
what are you really and you're the only
one there you see i'm pointing right at
you
you're the only one there so you're the
only one that can see
but as close as anyone can get you're
almost nothing
so we've teased i suppose the headless
way and we'll do some experiments in a
little bit that will allow
the watchers and the listeners to be
able to demonstrate this for themselves
how did douglas discover the headless
way he said he was asking himself
questions but he was an architect right
he wasn't sort of
out to simply wandering the earth in a
baggy pair of pants
no well he was brought up in lower staff
in suffolk
in the plymouth brethren which is a very
sort of fundamentalist christian group
and uh you know you're told what to
believe and what to
do and at 21 he left because he couldn't
accept that they were the
only path to god just because they said
they were
right you know that they didn't like
that
if it criticized them on theology they
could have defended it but you can't
defend yourself against
this is the truth because we say it's
true you know
so he left but he'd obviously been
deeply affected by
that kind of dedication to something
beyond himself i suppose you could say
but uh he then
qualified as an architect in london and
started working as an architect
and he uh got interested in trying to
understand himself
but he wasn't going to go and ask
someone else what the truth was about
him he'd done that you know
so he started looking for himself and he
looked scientifically and
philosophically
and realized he was made of layers like
i've just said
and he wasn't just human and he was made
of these billions of little animals
called cells
you know incredible or he was part
of society or part of the planet and
then he got married
he moved to india got a job in india and
then the war
broke out second world war and he
had developed this idea of
he was really intensely wanting to find
out who he was before he died
you know it was just he was just
hell-bent on that and
find out for himself and with all these
layers you know the nearer you get the
less
there is so it makes sense that there's
sort of some kind of nothingness at the
center
but then one day he was reading a book
on philosophy
and came across a drawing by a physicist
called ernst mark who was
in an article on perception and the guy
had drawn a picture of himself from his
own
point of view point of view first person
so there's a picture of
his body and his arms and legs and the
big nose and his moustache but no head
and when douglas saw this picture he
looked at himself so that's it
i've been trying to get to the center
from outside
and now i see i'm at the center looking
out and the center's empty
but full so then he spent the next seven
years
uh writing a book working on a book to
make sense of this in terms of science
he uh c.s lewis read it
described it as the work of that of
highest genius work of a house genius
and um wrote the preface for it got
published
and then in the following years i met
douglas in 1970
he developed his experiments for testing
this
idea that you're not what you look like
you know at six feet you're a person
with a head and in the mirror
what are you at zero and so a simple
you know experiment of pointing back at
yourself is to guide your attention
and he wrote many books and he explored
the implications of this
in in all kinds of areas
uh and uh met you know for the first 20
years after discovering this you didn't
share it
with anyone i think most people thought
he was mad
why well partly he was really involved
in writing the book
um but i don't know
he uh whenever he tried to share it with
someone people wouldn't look they just
think and say you're mad
you know of course i could head you know
well of course you have got to head from
there
but anyway in 1964 he shared it with his
secretary
in his architectural practice and he
then thought oh i can die now
i've shared it with one person right and
it was
a very dramatic sharing i mean it the
bells of heaven rang you know for her
but
um but then after that he gradually
shared it with more and more people
and more and more and it gathered
momentum in a way people saying yeah no
i get what you're talking about douglas
sure i'm built open um so
and then the more that people uh
kind of recognized it was true and
loving and helpful uh the more they
shared it as well
so here we are
what makes it loving and helpful
well you see uh it when you see
when you're with someone else and you
are consciously aware you don't see your
own face
then you're attentive to them you're out
of the way
it's very it's it's being attentive
and you're seeing that you're built open
for them so you're welcoming
you have their face you see you have
that well that's i mean that and you
recognizing i suppose too
that they for themselves they're also
this open space
full of you actually or whoever so
it is recognizing when you see who you
are when you see
your this open space full of the world
then you must accept everyone else is in
the same
wonderful condition which is very that
sort of namaste
um if you know the the the idea of
namaste you put your
hands together it's a greeting the 201.
i honor the the one in you it's the same
as the one in me you see well that's
headlessness you see the two
me and you are one i've got your face
you've got mine there's only one
consciousness here in that
respect so i i see chris you see
i'm getting to know chris a bit but i
know who you really
are which is this open space
what does built open mean you keep on
referring to that
well you see the thing is to have the
experience
and notice you can't see your head and
instead you see the world
that's almost the simplest way you could
say it but it's a non-verbal experience
so i'm using words just to articulate
this
non-verbal experience i can't see my
head now instead i see the world
so then i say that is if i had a head
here i'd be
closed i'd be behind a face
i'd be separate from you but i don't
have one here for me
so i say i'm built open but i mean this
is where you see you say
if you don't like you know if the words
i use
are not don't mean anything to you find
your own
because you've got it you can't see your
head instead you see the world
or when you're driving you're still and
the scenery is moving through you
you see that
insight about the fact that you are
static
and that the environment moves around
you when i first heard you
explain that i had to re-listen to it
about
five times and it's one of the most
interesting
insights that sits at the very forefront
of your
daily attention could you just explain
that to people for the uninitiated
that are watching and listening can you
just explain what you mean when you say
that you are static and the environment
moves around you
yes well the question that i keep coming
back to is what are you who
are you where are you living from that
makes all the difference
and if you're living from a thing
that is moving through the world that's
one thing
right and you understand that that's
what you look like but i
say test it out and point
back at your face and turn around on the
spot
and see if you turn or the room turns
now you knew this as a kid i mean you
love being
you know someone spin you around or
going on the roundabout because
the world goes for a spin and when
you're driving and relaxed and the
you notice that the scenery is moving
and you're still
you see so uh the experiment itself is
you just point back and turn around
on the spot and you notice that on the
other side of your finger the room is
moving and on the near side
there's no movement you're still now
this is fun it's true it's very relaxing
and uh you know if you go for a a
journey
uh from your point of view you go
nowhere and your journey come
your destination comes to you so in all
kinds of ways you can see how that's
relaxing
and fun you know or if you're dancing
you know you're still in the the
the circumstances are dancing or
you know moving around and so
this is finding that is a you know it
sounds
sounds superficial it's not you're
discovering this central stillness where
you are
it's always still it's not you know your
mind is moving
my mind is moving all the time but the
place i'm
i'm looking out of and thinking from is
still
now it's always still
now it makes a difference i would say it
really makes a difference to be aware of
that stillness
in the midst of movement it's very
uh relaxing and therapeutic and
simply noticing the fact that your
visual field is an oval
it sounds so stupid but i never realized
it
i know people don't we're in you know
all these uh
myths about people being in a dream you
know or under a spell
by a bad witch or something well we're
in a dream
you know we think we're looking at two
eyes and you look at the whole view now
i mean
people got to say what you really mean
just actually look at what you're
looking at yeah that's what i mean
right and when you're looking at the
actual
view then what you're looking at is most
in focus
and then if you have what they call
peripheral villi vision or soft eyes
then you include all the way to the edge
of the field of views so the viewer
or listener can do this now it's rather
fun you know it's very relaxing you you
notice all the way
you know to the edge where it fades out
you can't look at it directly you're
looking directly at the middle of the
view
but all the way around to the edge it
fades out then you say well what
is above it or what is to the left you
see
what is to there's nothing say oh
what do you mean i said there's nothing
you can't on present evidence not memory
or imagination
the whole view is floating in
consciousness
to suspend it there in the void you see
now this is weightless it's weightless
you're weightless
it's it's uh yeah
brilliant
what is a good experiment that we can do
to introduce people to the headless way
other than
the moving through space what's another
good way to do it
well the pointing one is a very simple
one
and uh again it is
testing the idea that you are
space for the world that you're not what
you look like what you look like you see
in the mirror
or other people see or photographs and
that's a person with a head
but the hypothesis i'm putting forward
is that
at center you for yourself are not a
thing you're nothing full of everything
so the way you do this is you get your
finger and you point out at something so
the viewer or listener has to take their
finger and look along it so you direct
your attention at something it is
it's worth doing you know rather than
just listening to me and when you look
along your thing you look at the thing
and it's got color and shape
and size and so on and it's surrounded
by other things
see now let's say you point at your
other hand
and it's the same it's a thing it's got
color and shape and movement and it's
got a background now you point back at
where others see your face so you turn
your finger around
and point now what do you see there do
you see your head do you see any colors
or shapes or background
i don't that's meditation that's
attention to what it's like to be you
and that it's as simple as that you
can't get it wrong
you see
[Laughter]
what is the implication
of the fact that your consciousness
emanates
from a particular spot and it is
difficult to be able to
observe that spot itself well i think
it's incredibly easy i
i uh things are difficult to observe you
know i'm looking off your face and
it's so complicated and and changing all
the time and
you know all of that but i look back at
my no face and it
what it's difficult to see about that
you see it it's absolutely obvious
it's your zen says it's your original
face
your true face your no face and
uh yeah i i i don't really understand
that question chris what's this
what's the implication of it what does
it mean
that okay when i try and observe myself
i can't see it what's the implication of
that
when you're looking at me you see you
can't see your own face
right what do you see instead
the bridge of my nose and the inside of
my
eye right and then further out than that
you see my face right
yes okay so you could say instead of
your face now
you see richards yeah
so is there any distance between you and
richard now
now you can measure say the distance
between my eyes between two things right
you could right but now measure between
richard's face
and the no thing you're looking out of i
mean there's no way you measure from
right
so so the whole world is not distant
it's given right where you are
it's yours it's yours you're infinitely
rich because it because
there's no distance from your point of
view it's all
in your awareness so you know
that is you've got your sort of
invisible arms around the whole universe
it's all in you it's not distant
everyone's face is your own
you know and also
uh this the space that you're looking
out of is not affected by
you know if if you uh make look at your
hand you see and you see your arm
and your shoulder and so your arm is
coming out of the headless you know it's
a headless body
the arm is coming out of your central
emptiness here
and there you can see it and now you
make your hand into a fist and it's
tense
is the central emptiness tense
no no the hand is tense
but nearer to you where you're looking
from is tension free
stress-free you see in the midst of
stress
just as the as it's free of movement in
the midst of movement
it's stress-free now to be aware in
our busy lives that we're still at
center or to be aware in our stressed
lives that we are at center stress
free that we're coming from a place
that is stress-free that is there
now this is meditation it's no good just
thinking about it you've got to
pay attention to it and uh
you know be aware of it and that's the
thing it's dead easy
to see your headless but the thing is
living from it
and practicing it and i think you've got
to want to
but it's not not as hard as it might
seem
you've just got to develop the habit you
know when when you're
around people start to notice it's face
to no face
see or when you're on your own notice
your single eye this this
oval shape of the world disappearing
see my hands disappear into nothing here
and then come out again
it's fun as well you see it's not a
somber
you know thing it's it it's light and
fun and it's very familiar i mean you're
like this is a baby
see just open so
uh you know or if if you close your eyes
for a moment and just ask yourself how
big are you
on present evidence not from memory
you've got sensations and thoughts and
feelings but i can't say how big i am
and the darkness is just you know how
big is the darkness i can't tell
how big am i i don't know so if you're
lying in bed just be aware
that you you you don't have a size or a
shape it's very relaxing
seeing that if you open your eyes now
then it's uh the world reappears in the
great void
you said that it's not a
somber or a super serious way to think
about meditation i think that you've
talked about someone referencing
douglas's
students or you always being able to
know where douglas's students were
because they're the ones that were
always laughing no with the buddhist
society now that yeah that was true
well yes yes it it
you see the thing is we we have groups
zoom groups
you know several a week and they're free
and anyone's welcome to join if you're
interested in this and you you know
you've tried the experiments but where
should they go for that
go to headless.org and you'll find
information about there
or you can contact me through
headless.org yeah
so um the thing is
that uh
i was saying about the groups that the
thing is that you
when you see who you are you realize
it's so simple
and everyone gets it so there isn't a
hierarchy
so i'm talking to you as an equal here
you see because
you know the space is as obvious to you
as it is to me
you'll have a different reaction to it
see but
to hang out with others who are aware of
this
and sharing their responses to it
uh isn't uh this sort of hierarchical
thing where one person's got it and
you've got to listen and write it all
down and try and behave
it it's like we've all got it and
let's share our different reactions to
it and that's infectious
so what i'm saying is that one way or
another
the thing is to get it going in your
life get into the habit of it
enjoy it and the more that you're aware
of it the more natural it becomes and
the more it benefits you
you discover you know what a what
a great benefit it is to live from this
yeah it seems to me that there's a
little bit of a
central paradox to try and
work out it sounds like at center we are
nothing
and yet at the same time we are all
the universe with its arms wrapped
around us
how can you can you explain another way
for me
and the listeners to to understand how
that
fits together
well uh the thing is to look and see if
it's true
you see that that's the it's not
primarily about
understanding it's about having a look
for yourself and then describing it
in the way that you think so
uh i'm only using my words to
describe this experience which i'm
absolutely convinced it's the same for
you and for everyone how could it not be
and for all animals actually
and so i i would say that looking here
you see with growing up you learn
to see yourself as others see you when
you're a baby you don't know
what you look like as a child you're
learning
to identify with the with the um
image in the mirror i'll turn that off
so as a child you're learning to find
out who you are in society which is what
other people see you to be
and you're learning to look in the
mirror and take that image and sort of
wear it and other people are projecting
your image back on you so you take that
on board
so by the time you're an adult you see
when you're a baby you haven't got that
yet you're just open
you're not self-conscious you've no idea
yet if i was a baby now and i was
looking at you i wouldn't have any idea
what you were seeing
and i'd just be looking you see and i
wouldn't be feeling self-conscious
and you as an adult would enjoy that
because you would know that
i'm not feeling self-conscious so you'd
relax into that
right it's it's it's uh infectious
now as you grow up everyone your parents
and everyone
reflects back to you what you look like
with the help of the mirror language so
by the time you're a child you're
getting a good idea of what you are but
you're still not
fixed in the box that you think you're
in you know it's as easy to be a lion as
a
little boy or girl you see because
you're not fixed yet
and your friends are all in the same
unfixed
place as well so you all play being
lions together until
mom or dad comes along and tells you
you're a little boy or a little girl or
whatever
you see oh right yeah i forgot
we forget that we were so open at the
time but we were but we know it we know
it
anyway by the time you're an adult uh
you've had 24 7 feedback
of what you look like and you absolutely
take that on board
that you are what you look like at
center for yourself that you're not open
space you're not nothing you're a thing
now that's really important obviously to
know so that you can function and
you know you know why people are talking
to you you know you've got this
understanding of who you are now most
people probably that's it
if you're growing up is finding out who
you are in society and then making
the best of the cards you've been dealt
but what the headless way is saying well
actually it's not the whole story
it's not the whole story about you
you now take a fresh look at what it's
like to be you you've got the objective
thing going
you see which you didn't have as a child
or a infant
you've got that going you don't have to
worry about that you're well
aware of what you look like you know who
you are your name where you live or
you've got that going now that you've
got that going
pause and take a moment to look for
yourself what it's like to be you
without all that feedback
you see when you play that game in a
party where they write
a famous film star name and put it on
your forehead
how do you find out you've got to ask
everyone
you can't see yourself you've got to ask
them it's the same growing up who am i
please tell me you see and then you
think now
you know who you are whether anyone's
telling you or not but the only way you
you do actually know is through others
so what the headless way is saying okay
you've got that going
now pause and just now look for yourself
don't rely on others
you've got that going it's not denying
that look for yourself
now be your own authority you've got to
stand on your own to do this and you're
going to say
right just for this moment i'm actually
going to pause
and actually pay attention to what it's
like to be me without
any help see
and that's what the experiments are
doing they're saying right
you have been under the deep conviction
that you are what you look like
you're with a head all right you got
that going but now pause and look for
yourself
and take seriously what you actually
experience
so you take a look you see they go oh
right
there isn't anything here except space
for the whole world
right that's you see so it's not asking
you to
take yet again or someone else what you
are
is saying no you be the authority on you
now
and you direct your attention back to
the place you're looking out of
and all you see this is in line with
what all the
great mystics have said that at your
center is a great treasure
so to a timeless treasure you see who
you really really are is amazing
so this is this is saying right well
let's have a look
you see right let's not believe let's
look
through yourself now are you looking out
of two eyes or out of one opening
you see do you move or does the world
move through
you are you face to face with others or
is it
face to no face when you close your eyes
do you have any boundaries
see when you think i mean
you you've been taught that your
thoughts come out your brain
or somewhere right out of something
you're
thinking those thoughts are now in your
head
you see well i i pay attention i think
of the number 10
i see i have no idea where that came
from
right i just came out the great void
they call it the no mind
right you see or think of the face of a
friend
i mean where did that come from it just
comes out
so you say oh okay right i've got the
idea i've got mine but when i look for
myself
i have no mind and my mind comes out of
that
now when you've got the idea that you've
got a mind in your head it's a very busy
place i mean a lot going on in a tiny
spot
you know you had a busy mind you know oh
my
my head's so busy it's so full you see
that's the
way we describe it you pay attention
and uh your thoughts coming out nowhere
out of great space you're free of your
thoughts where you are
you've got lots of thoughts i mean
actually it it improves creativity
because you're not
kind of limiting yourself so
uh this is uh then
you see i you start with the experience
you go straight to the experience
and then you explore what it means to
you and that's where it's so
much fun to be with others because you
get to hear
what they think as well you talked about
the mirror then looking back are there
any experiments that people can do using
a mirror if they're near one now
yes oh yes you get a mirror or you can
use your phone you know the selfie thing
and you hold it in your hand and you
look down your arm
and uh you you ask yourself it's
incredibly simple
all right i see my face there like i can
see it on the screen you see i see my
face out there
at the far end of my arm because i'm
holding my hand out with the mirror or
the phone
now do i see a face at the near end
no my arm disappears into open space
that my mirror shows me where my face is
it's out there on the screen
out in you out in the mirror in the
phone
but not at my center you see and what we
do when we grow up we you see the baby
doesn't
import that image the baby is another
the infant's another infant it's not you
and you've got to learn to put that face
on
so what you do in imagination is you
reach in
get hold of your little face there pull
it out imagination
flip it the other way around because
it's phasing the wrong way
you'll make it bigger because it's tiny
and you're going to marry it to these
sensations
you know because you can feel your mouth
but you can't see your mouth
right and in the mirror you can see your
mouth but you can't
feel it now if you want to know where to
put your food you're going to marry the
image
to the sensation right here it comes
into the air hangout you see
so you learn to
map that image in the mirror onto these
sensations and your back and your foot
and great great but you know
the image always when you do the
experiment you say oh
okay the image is there and i'm here
i am not my image
you know we all want hey stop defining
me you know all right well stop defining
yourself
that's that you know see that you're
undefined
then other people can define you till
their heart's content because it doesn't
stick
i like the experiment of thinking about
what it's like to
look at a child especially an infant or
a baby
and you are right there's an odd sense
of freedom
releasing when you are with another
creature
that doesn't see you in the same way
that you think other people see you
and i think that's the interesting thing
about self-consciousness right it's not
self-consciousness isn't i'm conscious
of myself it's i'm conscious of other
people being conscious of me
yes that's right you only know yourself
through others
that's right and so uh the baby
is it's not feeling self-conscious you
see they're just not
got a head on yet
just open see and that's very still in a
baby when a baby's not
you know hungry or something they're
just very still
and attentive and not self-conscious you
see
well we can't go back to that
but we can go on to awakening
to having no face for ourselves
you see and then it really makes a
difference because
you'll never control what people think
of you or
how they see you but you can control
whether or not you identify with it
you know you can pay attention now
to the place you're looking out of and
like in that game with the guess the
name of the film star on your forehead
you can't see
you know you're undefined for yourself
you can't define yourself
so but take that seriously you see for
me
i'm undefined now that i
i cannot be pinned down for me
now that makes a big difference when
everyone's trying to pin you down
your
it's a sanskrit term you're unpinnable
down
it's not the is that the technical term
yeah that's the technical term
talk to me about how the students that
you've worked with and the groups that
you've worked with
what are some of the ways that
realizing that the headless has helped
people in their
daily lives you've already identified it
takes a little bit of time
to go from perhaps a conceptual
realization to
building it up into a habit so that you
notice it throughout the day
but i imagine that identifying with
negative thoughts and emotions and
inner monologues and labels from other
people and nervousness and
self-consciousness
i imagine that these are some of the
primary places that it assists people at
least in their daily experience
yes i mean first of all i don't have
students i have friends
which is an important point really
that we're equal and
i can't see this space more clearly or
less clearly than anyone else
and anyone else's response to it
is as valid as mine and vice versa so
it's a sharing of equals
and uh
this makes this
really uh amongst the people that i know
and i i know lots of people who are
living from this and exploring its
benefits so finding out how it's
beneficial in their
lives i mean it just it helps in
almost every way you you can think um
i don't know where to start really uh
um you know you
it it somehow self-evident you've found
home
you've found home you're not seeking
anymore you've you've refined it you've
you've found home
now even if the world go goes to hell in
a handbasket
which it might well do you know you
internally you found home you're at home
because the world is at home in you
you're seeing that
you are you know i mean it's just
incredible you're not a thing in the
world
for yourself you're the space in which
the world is happening
that is safe you see so
you're recognizing it's kind of trying
to get used to having won the lottery
you can't spend it all at once but you
know like you won the lottery
right now enjoy it or live it or
you know that can't keep coming back to
it
you could only be aware of it now
right now you know it's not about
you know stretching it out it's just
available now
and so i am noticing that this
conversation is unfolding
in this space
and uh you are a guest in my awareness
right as it's the trees out the window
and the
bird it's a very friendly
uh place to come from
and it because we have grown up and been
educated in the opposite that
the world is strange and separate and
over there and people are not me
and we're all strangers and i'm gonna
die and
al all of that so
now you are discovering
the opposite is also true that's true
but the opposite
is also true so wow okay
let's hope i live a long life to sort of
drink this deep you know
and apply it and explore it and keep
coming back to it
and finding other people if i want to
you know who
are exploring this
living from this as well you know
so
i think i think also i suppose one
learns to
gradually learns to trust it somehow
you know who are you
you say well there's um
there's a story by rumi uh the persian
poet um
i read this douglas found this douglas
harding
and um a dervish a saint comes out of
the desert or out the
you know into the village and the guy in
the village recognizes he's a saint you
see someone who's aware of who he really
is like this you see
and you know when uh you you're by the
water and the sun's going down
the light of the sun comes across the
water to you no not to anyone else right
it doesn't go across the water to fred
it goes to you
to the source right and um
so anyway the guy comes out the desert
and and uh
the villagers said ah oh okay you know
he recognizes him as a saint he said how
are you
how are you and the guy said you're
asking me how i
am me for whom the sun rises the rivers
flow
you see the sun comes across the water
to me
and even the sun glinting on
you know somebody's tooth doesn't happen
without my permission
because i'm the source you see i'm the
center that's still still centered with
the turning one i'm the one you're
asking me how i
am i'm all right thanks
yes you see as who you really are you
are all right thanks
as richard i'm not you know uh uh
but as who i really am now that
you know you you who in their own
estimation is all right
really all the time i haven't met anyone
and i think they'd be
rather deluded if they did think they
were you see we have to live
with this you know crazy situation of
being a human being where we're always
making mistakes and trying our best but
you know very limited
so i mean self-awareness is at it's at
least in some part is accepting
that you put your foot in it you know
but who you really are doesn't put
his foot in it who you really are
your true nature is is just all right
more than all right and so it is a great
balance
to awareness of your limitations as a
person
to being aware of your the perfection of
who you really are
and there's always this to and fro
between your awareness of who you are as
a person
born and will die but your true nature
was never born and will never die so
that's a great
kind of counterbalance or
your human nature is stressed but your
true nature is unstressed we did that
experiment you know so that it's not
denying the stress
it's balancing it you see with the truth
or
you know your human nature is always in
motion but your true nature is still
so have that you know move back and
forth if you like
between those two poles of the battery
between those two
sides of yourself rather than just
focusing on one
it's interesting that you brought up
life and death there
i wondered whether the headless way had
any implications for
the shortness of life it's something
that a lot of philosophies and
people deal with the fact that if you
are
this nothing and everything if the
universe has its arms wrapped around you
you don't want that to go away well
first of all you say if you are well i
am i see i am it's not an if it's a
it's a i am so that's one thing i've got
to put you right there
and uh the other thing is is that you
could
you it's the that balance of opposites
really your human nature is
you know short
you know it's brief it comes and who
knows how long you're going to last
and we live with that every day everyone
does
so there's that reality but there's your
true nature which is not in time
i look from the timeless into time the
space isn't in time
and that embraces everything so you see
there's this balance
between this insecurity and uncertainty
and brevity
potentially of your human life or of
life
you see and your unchanging eternal
nature is who you really are which is
empty full always full of something and
that helps me cope better with the very
real
fact that i'm going to die and that
you know lots of bad things happen uh
in the world um
this is you see not a kind of
not trying to sell a philosophy it's
saying look for yourself
and then describe it you know but i say
you know one of our experiments is is
the time one
you know you you you're looking out into
time it's a certain time in
you know 10 to 7 or something whatever
it is
now what time is it where you are well
time and change go together don't they
it this meeting has lasted so far 50
minutes
and it's it's changing all the time
that's time
right now where you are do you see
anything changing
no
where there's no change there's no time
and i look from the time less into
time you get the best of both worlds so
you're not in denial
of either your time fullness or your
timelessness
can you remember what it's like to be
headed
of course i i'm aware of it every day
all the you know
just like everyone else but i am also
with my headlessness that's the
difference
so it's not like you i mean what on
earth would it be like
not to be aware of your head you'd be
gaga wouldn't you
you'd have to be taken to the hospital
you wouldn't be able to talk you
someone would look at you and you you
wouldn't know they were looking at
anything
like the baby right babies need taken
care of
but i've got my head on and now i'm
saying i
i for myself i don't and i distinguish
but you know i uh
i think that you see the thing is
that when you see your headless you
don't suddenly become headless
you realize you've always been headless
it's not suddenly oh you know i i
all the way up to my life till now i've
had a head and now i don't you realize
oh no i've never had one here
out there in the mirror in others in my
own
you know self-consciousness but right
here where i am i've never had one
now you say well actually
even though i didn't know it for my
whole life i've never had one
i've always been open i just didn't know
it
then you think well actually that's true
of everyone
everyone no one can see their own head
everyone is living
from their true nature so that's why we
don't go mad
because we're actually living from this
and when we drop our guard and relax
you know we're naturally headless you
see if we don't feel threatened
when we're with a baby you see we
naturally drop our defenses and
that surface that separates us
see but now you can do it consciously
you don't have to
you know wait for the kind of conditions
i wonder whether that is one of the
attractions that people see
with spending time with babies with
spending time with pets and animals
spending time in nature that
level of serenity and the lack of
neuroticism
focusing your thoughts about thoughts on
yourself
being pulled out into what it is that
you see around you without seeing
something that sees
you as you yes
that's right yes but you
that that's right and that is your
natural headlessness
you see when you're relaxed uh when
you're the baby when you're in nature
when you're not being
you know under inspection being looked
at then
you're headless if my terms but the
thing is
you can enjoy that when you're in a
crowd
you can consciously notice your headless
and space
for the world now
that is really useful yeah
richard lang ladies and gentlemen
headless.org
that's right if people want to keep up
to date and also you've got a
awesome new video on your youtube
channel
which will be linked in the show notes
below any other things that people
should check out
well if you're really interested to meet
others if you've done some of the
experiments
and the headless experiences is
meaningful to you i suppose i would say
and you want to meet others who are
living from this we have lots of zoom
meetings free ones each week
so there's a community online of people
who are
uh living from this and it's very
friendly
so through the website you can get in
touch with me and i can give you
information
and uh you're welcome yeah so
um i think that's probably
my that's probably the information to
give out yeah amazing richard
thank you so much thank you nice to meet
you nice to have your face chris
nice to be chris and you nice to meet
richard
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here
for a selection of the best clips from
the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe it makes
me very happy
peace